sono angelo riccaboni presidente della
fondazione prima e del santa chiara lab
dell'unità di siena e sono qui per fare
alcune riflessioni con voi sul tema
dell'innovazione settore agroalimentare
molto spesso questi due argomenti sono
considerati anche in contrasto tra di
loro perché si ritiene l'agricoltura un
settore conservatore un settore che non
cambia invece non è assolutamente così
abbiamo anche un esempio davanti a tutti
noi
e evidente che quello del pomodoro
pomodoro che qualcuno magari ritiene che
un ortaggio che è rimasto sempre nel
modo che vediamo adesso invece avuto una
storia molto interessante anche di
cambiamento infatti i pomodori sono
venuti in europa nel 1940 vengono dal
perù vengono dal messico e vengono in
francia in francia dove però non
crescono bene e dove sono piccoli gialli
d'altronde si chiamano per questo
pomodori come d'oro soltanto qualche
decennio dopo quando arrivano in italia
in particolare nel meridione d'italia
che assumono col rosso quella prosperità
che ora noi gli riconosciamo ma da
allora è stata tutta una storia di
cambiamenti fino a che ora abbiamo 320
diverse tipologie di pomodoro e questo
tra l'altro ho avuto anche ulteriori
cambiamenti degli ultimi anni dove sono
arrivate altri tipi altri specie quindi
questa è una storia che esprime quello
che è stato una caratteristica
dell'agricoltura del dottore che come
sappiamo avuto tre grandi trasformazioni
a prima una vera e propria rivoluzione
che è stata quella meccanica che ha
eliminato la schiavitù del lavoro molto
intenso troppo intenso dell'uomo nei
campi la seconda negli anni cinquanta è
stata quella cosiddetta rivoluzione e
chimica
quando abbiamo usato abbiamo cominciato
a usare di prodotti nella terra che
hanno aumentato le rese
e ora siamo nel pieno di una rivoluzione
che non tutti forse conoscono che la
rivoluzione digitale usare i droni
sensori la famosa block cena
l'intelligenza artificiale l'internet of
things per produrre usando meno risorse
naturali meno acqua meno terra meno
pesticidi un grande cambiamento in corso
e questo è molto importante specialmente
specialmente oggi
oggi viviamo nell'epoca possiamo
chiamarla così covip covic ha insegnato
parecchie cose
fra le cose che ci ha insegnato per
sistemi agroalimentari ne possiamo
ricordare tre a prima mi sembra
abbastanza evidente
il cibo è diventato molto più importanti
per tutti nella nostra scala dei valori
sicuramente è diventato un argomento
molto più centrale di prima secondo per
la prima volta abbiamo avuto dei
problemi di approvvigionamento cioè ci
siamo posti la questione potrebbe essere
che sulle nostre tavole non arrivano i
prodotti che invece solitamente ci sono
terzo abbiamo capito che fra modi di
produzione del cibo
il cibo che noi mangiamo la salute
nostra e la salute dell'ambiente c'è una
connessione molto molto stretta molto
forte e questo abbiamo capito perché
purtroppo le persone per esempio che
avevano delle malattie che spesso
derivavano dalla nutrizione sono state
quelle più colpite dal co vide abbiamo
capito perché purtroppo c'è stato un
trasferimento da il mondo animale al
mondo umano del virus dovuta al fatto
che noi abbiamo per anni per decenni
prodotto il cibo ovvero tramite nel
disboscamento deforestazione un
eccessivo uso della terra in maniera non
sostenibile
quindi questi tre argomenti sono
sicuramente oggi al centro
dell'attenzione tutti quanti in questo
nuovo contesto noi dobbiamo conciliare
tre aspetti
l'attenzione alla sostenibilità
ambientale ma anche sociale
quindi si sa fare in modo che non
abbiamo ricadute negative sull'ambiente
ma anche fa sì che le persone siano
trattato nel modo corretto
secondo le dimensioni delle nostre
imprese agroalimentari che tipicamente
su dimensioni minime e terzo riuscirà a
dare ai produttori il giusto tasso di
redditività perché se abbiamo detto che
cibo importante dobbiamo avere rispetto
per chi produce il cibo ha come
conciliare questi tre aspetti è una
risposta importante un contributo
importante lo può dare
l'innovazione l'innovazione che
sicuramente tecnologica ma anche
innovazione organizzativa cosa significa
innovazione organizzativa rivedere il
modo in cui noi facciamo le cose fare
delle nuove alleanze con quelli che
magari prima nelle nostre competitor
vuol dire rivedere la nostra struttura
organizzativa all'interno vuol dire
lanciarci sui mercati con magari nuove
idee
quindi c'è anche un innovazione
organizzativa estremamente importante
tutte e due
aiutano a conciliare i tre temi che ora
abbiamo ricordato molti l'ho già lo
stanno facendo ci sono molti casi
interessanti vi voglio raccontare
brevemente un caso che ci ha colpito
quello di manuele vita un produttore
siciliano di agrigento
il quale soffriva producendo riproduceva
l'uva da tavola vittoria producendo una
soffriva della concorrenza dei
produttori che dalla costa sud del
mediterraneo riuscivano arrivare prima
sui mercati
lui alla fine è riuscito ad anticipare
addirittura loro addirittura avere due
produzioni per anno e questo grazie alla
produzione di uva fuori suolo che riesce
a produrre ben 16 mila piante per ettaro
rispetto alle 2000 che sono tipiche
delle produzioni usa in maniera molto
efficiente
l'acqua e quindi a sia riduzione
dell'uso dell'acqua sia produzione più
intensa ma più che altro è riuscita
anticipare i propri concorrenti e questo
ha fatto sì che in pochi anni si è
riuscito a ottenere degli ottimi
risultati anche dal punto di vista
economico quindi molto importante
l'innovazione è molto importante
rilevarla valorizzarla condividerla
questo è un bellissimo esempio ce ne
sono molti altri di esempi questi esempi
noi l'abbiamo raccolti in un
osservatorio che si chiama prima
observatory on innovation questo è stato
effettuato da parte del segretariato
italiano di prima perché vogliamo
proprio promuovere la conoscenza di
queste belle esperienze per valorizzarla
ma per far sì che magari altri
imprenditori possano prendere spunto da
queste belle iniziative magari replicare
e migliorarle nel loro contesto
questo perché in effetti il settore
agrifood se innovativo può essere una
leva di sviluppo per il mediterraneo e
questo non è strano perché tutto il
mondo tutto il mondo ci invidia
la qualità dei prodotti in particolare
quella che è la dieta mediterranea che
fu proprio in qualche modo inventata 60
anni fa nel cilento
questo è un auspicio che noi speriamo
che si realizzi ci sono le condizioni ci
vuole sicuramente come abbiamo detto
innovazione ci vuole sicuramente
investimenti pubblici ci vuole un cambio
di mentalità da parte dell'imprenditore
concludo ricordando un episodio sempre
parlando di cibo aveva parlato di
pomodori abbiamo parlato
di uva se parliamo per esempio di mele
ci ricordiamo dell'episodio di newton
che come ricordiamo nel 1665 fu colpito
testa non amerà italy secondo la storia
e la leggenda discesa delle conseguenze
importanti per il mondo della fisica per
il mondo per il mobbing comprendiamo il
mondo
ebbene non tutti sanno che in
quell'occasione era nelle campagne
inglesi la causa di una quarantena
allora perché ricordo questo episodio
perché in effetti anche tutti quanti noi
i nostri imprenditori nostre
imprenditrici gli uomini e donne
impegnati nei settori agroalimentari
anche se siamo in una situazione
certamente non facile grazie
all'intelligenza grazie all'innovazione
possono possiamo contribuire a
migliorare il mondo per avere un futuro
più giusto e sostenibile grazie
[Applauso]